Not only are you gonna redo the
memes, you are gonna become the memes.
“You get a car!
And you get a car!
And everybody gets a car!”
- [Laughing offscreen]
It’s not often that I can say immediately
that’s gonna break the internet.
- That’ll probably destroy the internet.
- Lefkoe here in New York City, where we’re
gonna meet up with
rookie Quinnen Williams of the Jets.
- [Sneezing]
Bless you.
Thank you.
I’mma go play with myself today.
That came out weird.
- Unfortunately, we got a flat tire, so
I’m gonna use my State Farm mobile app to get
some roadside assistance.
This is definitely Manhattan.
Definitely.
Just like this is definitely not
just a bit that we wrote
to feature the State Farm mobile app.
Let’s go talk to Quinnen Williams, shall we?
“Ditch the Playbook.”
♪♪♪
Let’s go!
Big Q!
- [Laughing]
- Welcome to Bleacher Report.
- Aw, man. This is dope, man.
- [Lefkoe] You’re pretty much
like a walking meme as it is.
- [Williams] Oh, yeah.
- [Lefkoe] So let’s make you
the king of the internet.
This is our meme laboratory.
Our meme factory.
- [Williams] It’s dope.
- [Lefkoe] There are memes out there that I
think are great, but they could be better.
Not only are you gonna redo the
memes, you are gonna become the memes.
- [Williams] Oh, yeah.
- Here’s your first prop of the day.
- OK.
- I’m so happy I got a teacup.
I was just thinkin’ in my head,
like, how’m I gonna do tea—
- Nah, man. We got, we got you
set up for everything.
What does the Kermit tea
meme—when would you use that?
- Like, somebody got tea?
- So, it’s sort—it really means:
“That’s none of my business.”
- Ohhh.
- So he’s just gonna sit there and drink
his tea, cuz “That’s none of my business.”
- All right, bet. I gotcha.
- You get it?
- I’m tired of Kermit.
- I need Quinnen doin’ this.
- Fosho.
Ahhh.
- [Laughing offscreen]
- [Lefkoe] That was perfect.
How did you feel about that?
Did that feel up to your artistic endeavors?
- Yeah, it definitely brought it out.
- Good.
- I feel like Vin Diesel.
- Our next one is going to be…
- [Williams] Oh, that’s my—that’s the one.
I love that one.
- You like this GIF.
- I love that one, definitely. That's dope.
- So when would you use this meme?
- Like, when I, when somebody say somethin’,
uh—like, when somebody ask me a question that
they already know, I’ll be like,
like, “Think about it, bro, like.”
- See, this to me is you rush the quarterback,
and you go, “Oh, this is way too easy.”
Screen, you make the tackle,
and people are like, “Wow!”
And you’re just like, “I knew all along. All along."
There’s one more thing we need to do.
- Ohhh, yes!
- I look—
- [Offscreen] : That’s so good.
- [Lefkoe] Is this your first mustache ever?
- Ever.
- Dude, your whole energy is different
now that you have a mustache.
- I look old!
- [Laughing offscreen]
- [Lefkoe] Oooh, that’s a good one.
Oooh!
That shirt does look good.
- [Offscreen] I agree.
- [Lefkoe] Do you know who that guy is?
- Adam Schefter?
- Adam Schefter?!
- Ain’t that the big dude that plays movies—
- You thinkin’ of Adam Sandler?
- Adam Sandler.
- That’s Chris Farley.
They hung out a lot.
When would you use this for football?
- After, uh, Le’Veon juke,
like, two, three people.
- Oooh.
“Holy crap.”
- [Williams] Yeah.
- So to sell this—it’s
all about the glasses.
- It’s definitely about the glasses.
And these the perfect glasses too.
- [Laughing]
- [Lefkoe] That’s awesome.
How’d that one feel?
- [Williams] That one was dope.
I like that one.
- So this is, this is after a win—
- Yeah.
- This is after a sack fumble
recovery for a touchdown.
- Fosho.
- This is, this is you get a chance
to meet Aaron Rodgers after a game.
- I seen Aaron Rodgers.
He look—he like, he gettin’ old, man.
He got a mustache, and,
like, he look funny now.
- He wore all the jean–
- He wore all that, yeah.
- I mean, I guess you could call Aaron
Rodgers old if you feel confident.
You better be careful though, man.
- [Laughing]
- We need you to dress like Oprah, though.
- Oprah?
Lemme see.
- Look at this.
Rick James is in the house, everybody.
How do you feel right now?
- I feel, I feel— [Laughing]
- [Laughing offscreen]
- [Lefkoe] That’s awesome.
It’s not often that I can say immediately
that’s gonna break the internet.
- That’s definitely gonna
break the internet right there.
That’ll probably destroy the internet.
- I know he likes it, cuz we’re
FaceTiming everybody in his phone.
- Everybody, this right here.
Look!
- [Person on phone] Give me one sec.
- ♪♪♪ And I-I-I will always love youuu. ♪♪♪
- [Laughing]
This so funny!
- [Person on phone] : Yeah,
what are you doing, you weirdo?!
- To me, when you have an
incredible play, this is the one.
A top-five meme of all time?
- [Williams] Yeah.
- I need to come out of the
screen and then be like—
- I got my part already down.
- Yeah, your part’s done.
My part’s the hard part.
OK. You ready, Q?
- Yeah.
- OK, me too.
- [Laughing offscreen]
- Are you ready to see these
spread all over the internet?
- I’m definitely ready.
I mean, I know for sure I’mma be usin’ ‘em.
I know for sure my fans and the Jets
fans and the nation gonna be usin’ ‘em.
So, they dope.
- Now, we gonna play my favorite meme.
- [Offscreen] : Give it up for
Quinnen Williams, everybody!
- [Applauding offscreen]
- [Lefkoe] My man.
That was awesome.
- I’ll let you guys have that.
- Hi, I'm Johnathan Abram,
safety with the Oakland Raiders.
Subscribe to Bleacher Report on YouTube for
more of Ditch The Playbook with Adam Lefkoe.
- [Offscreen] Nice.